我叫 Frederick，是 Victor 的联合创始人。Victor 是一名 AI 员工，可能在座大多数人已经听说过。它最近真的爆了。我们今年二月发布它时，完全没指望会增长，它其实只是一个实验。结果它让我们所有人都很意外：立刻找到了产品市场契合点，在全球范围内被大量采用。然后，我们现在已经有点追不上了。
我们确实追不上。那么 Victor 到底是什么？Victor 是一名 AI 员工。你可以把 AI 员工想象成一个人类员工。它待在你工作的地方，也就是 Slack。它没有单独的网页应用。就像你的同事一样，你不需要去另一个地方召唤它。它会参与你的讨论，出现在 thread 里，也出现在频道里。
它还能访问你能访问的工具。它支持三千个集成。如果某些集成它暂时没有，它也可以自己搭连接。也就是说，Victor 基本可以使用你公司正在用的任何工具。因此，它拥有来自所有工具的上下文。和人类员工不同的是，Victor 对整个公司拥有横向的、广泛的上下文。
比如说，当你现在雇一个 CMO，你大概可以想象，如果这个 CMO 能访问你的代码库，甚至能给代码库做贡献，那他会强很多。Victor 可以做到这一点。所以它把这种接近博士级的通用理解能力，带到了公司里的各个领域。
先快速讲一下 Victor 和我们公司的故事。早在 2023 年，我们的使命就是构建 AI 员工。那时 ChatGPT 刚发布不久。
但当时我们认为，构建 AI 员工的正确方式是通过浏览器。提醒一下，那时还没有 tool calling，也没有很强的代码生成模型。
当时要让 AI 采取行动，可能最合理的方式就是浏览器。浏览器是非常通用的界面，你基本可以通过浏览器使用任何工具，大多数应用也都有网页端。当时这个东西叫 Jace AI，它的工作方式是：截取 DOM 快照，用无损方式把它压缩变小。
然后根据这个快照、压缩后的快照以及你的目标，决定下一步该做什么。比如，我是不是应该在 Google 搜索框里输入点什么？或者我是不是应该点击登录按钮？这听起来很棒，对吧？理论上当然应该能工作。
它确实能工作，但在当时模型能力下，它无法连续完成太多步骤。2023 年的时候，它大概能可靠地做三到五步。这里说的可靠，也就是大概百分之六十的可靠率。而这个可靠率会随着每一步不断叠乘下降。
即便如此，那已经是当时的最先进水平了。Jace AI 是 WebArena 这个最流行的智能体基准上表现最好的网页智能体之一。它表现不错，但要把它做成真正有用的产品非常困难，主要问题是可靠性和速度。现在你可以直接调用几个工具或函数，马上拿到输出；但网页智能体常常要等一分钟，最后还失败。所以很难。不过网页智能体本身很了不起。
它们现在终于比过去好用多了。
后来，Jace 变成了一个邮件智能体。Sonnet 3.5 出来之后，我们构建了第一个 agent loop。我们非常想要一种体验：你不用打开一个网页应用去要求智能体做事，而是智能体本身已经有足够上下文，并且能主动为你提出任务。
我们用 Jace 实现了这一点。Jace 是一个很棒的产品，也有很好的产品市场契合。
它现在仍然活着，大家可以去试试。基本工作方式是：每当一封邮件到来，就会触发一个智能体，它连接你的工具，不仅可以用邮件草稿来回复邮件，也可以调用工具代码。比如有人要求退款，智能体可以自动帮你退款。当然，也可以加上审批门槛。
然后到了今年二月，我们发布了 Victor。Victor，我想这里大家都知道 OpenClaw，毕竟我们在 OpenClaw 这个 track 里。OpenClaw 是个人智能体，而我们一直想构建的是员工，也就是公司智能体。
你首先应该问自己的问题是：它们到底有什么不同？公司智能体和个人智能体有什么区别？第一，我们认为公司智能体应该待在你工作的地方，和你一起工作，并拥有公司上下文。
如果你做的是个人智能体，公司里的每个人大概都要连接自己的集成，然后各自运行自己的智能体。但 Victor 和公司智能体不一样。突然之间，只要公司里一个人连接了某个集成，Victor 就可以继承这些集成的权限，或者你可以调整权限，然后整个团队都能使用它。你不需要重复连接一百次。
所以就像我前面说的，三千个工具，待在 Slack 里，几乎能跨角色做任何事。但这也带来了挑战。大家可以想象，
我这里主要讲一个挑战。从个人智能体变成团队智能体，从一个用户变成任意多个用户，首先遇到的是记忆问题。对 OpenClaw 来说，记忆随着时间变得混乱是一个很大的担忧。我认为这确实很严重，担心它是合理的。
但想象一下，同样的架构、同样的记忆，现在不是给一个用户用，而是给一百个用户用。那它大概会以一百倍的速度把记忆塞爆。这是一个必须解决的大挑战，而我们已经解决了。另一个问题是 Slack 有不同频道。
公司还有不同层级结构，我们必须遵守。人们也经常会给智能体互相冲突的指令。设想你有一个公司智能体 Victor，它在增长频道里，也在工程频道里，还在人们的私信里。Victor 会从增长频道获取上下文，也可能从高管频道获取上下文。
你必须确保这些上下文不会泄露到工程频道或客服频道。同样，如果你在私信里向 Victor 说自己的问题，除非你属于增长团队，否则 Victor 不应该拿增长频道的上下文来回答你。所以访问结构会变得非常复杂。
我们选择 Slack 作为我们心目中“公司 AGI”的界面，是有原因的。我会先讲原因，再讲 Slack 里会坏掉什么。主要有两个原因。第一，我们希望 Victor 感觉像一个人类员工。你不会在网页应用里和人类员工互动，你会在 Slack 里和你的队友互动，对吧？
选择 Slack 作为界面的第二个原因是：如果 Victor 是一个非常强大的智能体，要执行困难任务，那这些任务不会立刻完成。它们可能自然就需要十分钟。所以当你打开网页应用，让一个智能体帮你做事时，
你已经切换了上下文。现在你还得等十分钟才拿到答案或输出，这会非常令人沮丧。你不想等。因为你已经习惯了 ChatGPT 那种即时回答：三十秒出结果，复制粘贴，然后结束。但强智能体不是这样工作的。那为什么 Slack 更好？因为如果你在 Slack 上 ping 一个人，让他帮你做一个应用，
十分钟后他给你一个答案，你会非常震惊。
没有任何队友曾经在十分钟内给你做出一个应用。所以感知完全不同。和正常 Slack 体验相比，这个延迟突然就显得很低。但 Slack 也会坏掉一些东西。第一，当你在网页应用里工作时，你通常只有一条单一线程。你打开一个新智能体或新线程，然后和它对话。
但在 Slack 里，你有很多交互模式。你可以私信别人，也可以在公共频道参与 thread，还可以只用 emoji 反应。你还可以编辑消息等等。所有这些都是智能体的输入，而所有这些又必须以某种方式放进线性的上下文里。它不是单一线程，所以我们必须管理它。
举个例子。一个人删除消息时，人类通常会默认：这个任务不该继续了，或者它已经不重要了。
当有人编辑消息时，你也应该对编辑做出反应。但假设你正在私信你的同事，不管是 Victor 还是你的朋友，然后你在 Slack 里开了一个 thread。到某个时候，人们经常会忘记 thread，然后直接给同一个人发一条新的 DM。那这时你应该重新开始、打开一个新的沙箱吗？
人类通常会带着上一个 thread 的上下文继续。但对智能体来说，那完全是一个新的区域，一个新的任务。所以需要发生的事情是：每次 Victor 收到 DM 时，都要看之前的消息，并以某种方式把它们滚动接续到现有对话里。这只是你需要面对的挑战之一。
一个有趣的事实是，我们注意到语气非常重要。我一开始没想到它会这么重要。给大家举一个客户例子。
我们现在 Victor 主要用 Opus 4.6。我们想试试 GPT 5.4，因为在工具调用和代码生成上，它真的很强，理论上应该能用，而且也更便宜。那为什么不把 Opus 换成 GPT 5.4 呢？有一个原因让我们没有这么做。原因不止一个，但最有意思的是个性。
不知道是不是因为我们的架构，但用户就是很喜欢 Opus。当我们做 A/B 测试时，他们全都开始炸锅。所以我觉得那个模型里有某种很美的东西，值得我们学习。Victor 里的 Opus 也有点嘴欠，我不确定这是我们团队调出来的，还是它本来如此，但真的挺有意思。我鼓励大家试试。接下来讲主动性。
Victor 能做的一件强大的事，是主动建议它可以帮你自动化哪些工作流。比如你在增长团队里，大家正在讨论一个 A/B 测试和它的结果。聊着聊着，你意识到某个选项表现很好，于是说，好，那我就选这个方案，不选另一个了。
Victor 可以访问你们用来做分析的工具，它真的可以检查并判断你说的是不是胡扯。
有几次我们在讨论实验时，Victor 去查了 PostHog，然后说：你说的没错，但这个结果没有统计显著性。接着它还跑了一个计算，解释为什么我刚才是在乱说。这很有趣，也是一个优势。如果 Victor 能突然加入对话并提供帮助，它就会在工作区里被更广泛地激活，这对产品很好。但如果 Victor 第一天就这么做，实际上也发生过，
安全团队会直接炸锅。因为有人把 Victor 加进工作区之后，Victor 突然开始私信所有人、参与各种 thread，安全团队就会紧张到不行。所以我认为，你应该先在少数用户那里赢得信任，然后再更广泛地推出。没错。
然后讲共享上下文的价值。我剩下时间不多了，所以很快讲一下 Victor 和 Claude Code 或 Claude Cowork 这类智能体的区别。Claude Cowork 在你的桌面上工作，所以有点不一样。Victor 的优势是它在云端工作，你不需要电脑一直开着它也能运行。另一个优势是共享上下文。就像我一开始说的，
为了让 Victor 好用，比如你要让它修改 Meta 广告预算，或者读取分析数据，只需要公司里一个人连接这个集成。想象你在一个一百人的团队里，增长团队有二十个人。如果你必须让这二十个人每个人都单独连接一次 Meta 广告，那会非常痛苦。
而且如果 Victor 想主动行动，而每个人都连接自己的集成，某个人也可能连接了自己的集成。Victor 就会被卡住，可能不知道该用哪一个集成，这会给用户增加很多复杂性。这里我想强调的是：Victor 不是一个工具，它是一次招聘。
我来讲一个客户故事。美国最大的电商品牌之一，他们的团队管理员连接了 Victor。他们连接的第一个团队集成，是他的个人邮箱，个人 Gmail。然后团队突然开始和 Victor 讨论这个人的邮件。
这个人就发消息给我说，兄弟，什么情况？Victor 在泄露我所有数据，你们为什么这么做？我说，你为什么要给 Victor 访问你的个人邮箱？如果你雇了一个新员工，你会给他访问你的个人邮箱吗？
大概率不会，对吧？不过这也给了我们很好的启发。于是我们给 Victor 增加了一个能力，可以限定集成的作用范围。所以集成不再总是共享的。如果你想把个人邮箱作为个人集成，让 Victor 在你的私信里，或者你公开调用它时使用，现在也可以做到。
总结一下，一个优秀的 AI 同事需要什么？如果你想构建自己的 AI 同事，我认为有三大支柱。这里是技术观众，所以我也鼓励大家试着构建自己的 Victor。
你只需要让三件事跑起来。第一，帮人把事情做完，这相对容易。现在模型已经有能力了，连接你的集成，比如通过 Pipedream，就能工作得不错。第二，了解公司，也就是拥有来自 Slack 的上下文，并确保你能好好利用这些上下文。你可能需要走 Slack 的审批流程，这很难，也可能很无聊。
第三，让它友好。这真的会带来差异。你要确保 Victor 喜欢你的团队，你的团队也喜欢 Victor。这就是我们对未来的愿景：每家公司都有 AI 员工。我觉得这很明显，没什么好争的。
从历史上看，我想强调一下，AGI 的愿景从十七世纪就已经存在了。微积分的发明者 Gottfried Leibniz 当时就在思考，人类不应该做那些不必要的事情，他想造一台计算器。但他当时不知道，计算并不是唯一可以被自动化的认知任务。
我们现在正处在历史上一个很美妙的时刻：我们基本可以自动化所有认知任务，并且我们可以参与这场革命。所以我想读一下他的那句话：优秀的人像奴隶一样浪费数小时做计算，是不值得的。让我们把这件事交给机器。最后，我想鼓励大家，
扫一下这个二维码，点击注册，把 Victor 加到你的 Slack 里试试。这个房间里的每个人都有一百美元免费额度，没有任何附加条件。你随时可以把 Victor 移除。它一定会带来很多价值，我保证。如果没有，给我打电话，我会确保它有价值。谢谢。